now the final habit in Covey's seven
Habits of Highly Effective People is
what he called sharpening the saw in
other words doing things too if you're a
manager you want to work on making sure
you have good values he stresses values
in his book you know developing certain
skills whether it be the ability to use
certain modern technology or if you're a
professional in some field you need to
constantly take courses to make sure
you're up-to-date and so forth in the
case of language learning there are a
number of ways in which we can sort of
sharpen our saw one of them is simply
through exposure to the language and
building up your vocabulary because a
good vocabulary is gonna help you in
every situation also I find that an
occasional review of grammar especially
if the grammar is heavy two examples
rather than explanations the brain has
trouble dealing with theoretical
explanations but the brain is very good
at at creating at recognizing patterns
and creating connections that relate to
patterns so I find it useful to review
patterns so that it makes me more
conscious of certain structures and then
I start to notice them better so that an
occasional review of grammar another way
of sharpening the saw is actually to
start speaking because it's all gonna
make you more attentive but but if we
take this this this sort of image of
sharpening the saw so we are doing
something that is not urgent in other
words rather than sort of being all
concerned about this next engagement
with the language and I won't understand
it I won't be able to say what I want to
say it's thinking that I am doing
something that is going to build up my
skills for the future so what I'm doing
is important but it's not urgent I'm
developing my skills therefore I have
this sense of of and we can you know
satisfaction achievement I'm doing
things to improve my skills and the
benefits will come will come later on
and so I think we can have a sort of
sharpening the saw
to all of our language learning
activities so that we don't get
discouraged when we feel that we're not
making as much progress as as we would
like because all of our activities are
actually improving our skills and the
benefits will flow to us later on so
there it is I've tried to in these short
videos kind of go over again how cubbies
seven Habits of Highly Effective People
has application for us in our language
learning and I hope it kind of helps to
stimulate you to put that effort in to
you know reaching your language goals
thank you for listening bye